dernière répétition avant le grand show
du théâtre de champ fleuri
l'équipe de slameurs du collège plateau
caillou s'est réuni pour faire les
derniers ajustements aux commandes leur
professeur de français passionné de slam
qui leur a imposé un thème d'actualité
la tolérance je suis la tolérance que tu
sois noir ou blanc je te regarde sans
méfiance
que tous soient chrétiens ou musulmans
nous avons le même sens nous sommes mais
poussière nous mourrons poussière c'est
pas ça ça on est sûr de soi d'accord
attention et oui je m'en tous les cris
en même temps débrouillez vous faut
qu'ils aient choisi c'est vrai c'est moi
qui ai aussi choisi le titre je suis la
tolérance en rapport avec les tragiques
événements qui sont arrivés au début de
l'année les attentats donc contre
charlie hebdo m'a semblé vraiment
important de les sensibiliser à ce thème
la tolérance l'acceptation de l'autre au
sein de l'établissement en dehors et
dans la vie tout simplement donc
évidemment faire un rapport externe
d'actualiser c'était évident tant des
jeunes qui écrivent des textes qui à
travers le slam ont trouvé leur moyen
d'expression
c'est ainsi qu'ils se sont retrouvés
tout au long de l'année pour pouvoir
mettre en poésie leurs ressentis
d'adolescents de tuer la tolérance je
suis la tolérance je n'ai pas besoin de
mes différences j'ai appris à vivre avec
le respect dans un monde d'égalité thème
nous a été donnée par le professeur
et aussi ce qui m'a inspiré ben c'est
tout ce qu'on voit à la télé dans le
collège retour par exemple
dans ma classe c a déjà eu des propos
racistes 120 garçons et jeunes du match
côté ça on voit plein de des gens qui va
la vie je respectais pas ça du coup on
en parle pour les faire comprendre que
au final bah c'est pas bien et tout bas
ça l'fait des sas et du fonds se
reconnaître et ça les fera peut-être
réfléchir ressemble beaucoup au rap et
au brésil
la liberté d'expression tu perds une
dextérité émotions mais liberté
d'expression ne rime pas avec prétention
site expliquait il ne fait pas à pointe
claire
il ne faut pas que sumo prime alors
prends un crayon et délivrera de sept
présents au concours de slam qui est
apparue comme une aubaine puisque ces
collégiens pourront se confronter à
d'autres collégiens sur une grande scène
l'occasion peut-être de découvrir des
talents et pour leurs professeurs le
plus important c'est bien sûr de
participer je vais pouvoir quand même
déjà présente à mes élèves sur scène
après je sais qu'il y en a qui se
prépare depuis le début de l'année à ça
moi je les fais en cours d'année
j'espère quand même que ça va aller
on a fait du bon travail mais
l'important c'est qu'il soit sur scène
et qui se donne rendez vous mardi
prochain pour la grande finale au
théâtre de champ fleuri